a year-long investigation has found
former British prime minister Boris
Johnson deliberately misled Parliament
about the coveted lockdown parties at
his office the scathing report released
today by the House of Commons privileges
committee found Johnson's actions were
such a flagrant violation of the rules
they warranted a 90-day suspension from
Parliament the committee also accused
Johnson of being complicit in a campaign
of abuse and attempted intimidation but
the recommendation is largely symbolic
because Johnson quit as a lawmaker on
Friday the former leader maintains his
innocence and is condemning the report
as rubbish well I think the Privileges
committee is pretty damn it you know
it's serious Boris Johnson is not only a
law breaker but a liar he's not fit for
public office and he's disgraced himself
and continues to act like a you know
pound shot Trump in the way in which he
tries to discredit anybody who
criticizes his actions when actually a
decent public servant would have done
the honorable thing would have had a
little bit of humility and would have
apologized to the British public for
what they put them through yeah I think
I always have that sort of like inkling
that he was sort of that way inclined
but um yeah I think now that it's sort
of been confirmed I think my I think my
opinion has sort of gone down from Boris
Johnson so I just don't like him at all
I never liked him to begin with and now
I just feel like he just shows time and
time again how much of a buffoon he is I
think he resisted a bit too hard he
probably should have stepped out of it
earlier
um so that may you know maybe he kind of
clung onto power a bit kind of reminded
me of a good good old Trump but um at
the end of the day you know he was
trying to do something
um and he obviously believed in it so
I've got to respect that he's likable
and funny but just should never have
been in that role in the first place
why is that
he's proven again not to respect
governments